how are you guys good yeah yeah judd was
just saying that the thing about working
with canadians is they never stop
talking about canada yeah
i'm eventually slowed down a bit jay
bearshell though yeah don't get that guy
started yeah yeah are you an expert now
you work with these guys and sandra on
the other show are you becoming like an
expert in all things canadians i sort of
just tuned it out you probably hate that
yeah
anything in the world you were telling
me sandra talks about it a lot right
yeah there's always like in canada like
that's what americans
this is a very canadian story in a way
because everybody i know who's from
canada that comes to la all they end up
doing is sitting around with their dude
smoking pot
that's the canadian story coming in the
whole thing is just canadian
people go to l.a how much
aside from the being successful part how
much of this guy is you
um i'd say at times
very much
at other times not at all but
uh
yeah there are moments in the movie that
literally could be lifted directly from
my life yeah
the stuff with the roommates is pretty
close to home at times
and um
i don't know i'm not quite as dumb as
maybe
nothing
you can drop stuff
uh yeah i'm uh i'm pretty much exactly
like yeah character in many ways um
would this have worked as well if
you weren't so far out of his league in
the movie
because a lot of women i know will will
go for funny before they'll go forward
are you that kind of girl yeah almost
every woman i know is that kind of girl
really so i was saying this earlier
mostly behind the horn yes guys uh look
how gorgeous your girlfriend is like
guys don't think it's good guys don't
think it's true but i think it's a
little more true than people yeah
generally aim for the stars man yeah
okay so so if you're on if you're on the
list you're on the maximum list which
just came out if you're in charge of the
maxim list yes you are
the maximum hot one for you at i don't
know are you kidding i think you're like
14 or something like that what out of
what
but if you're in charge of the guys list
where are you where are you putting seth
i'm putting seth at
three yeah after josh kelly after josh
josh is one and then george clooney and
then maybe clooney navy clooney menu
it's not bad company four